I’ve written a film that’s
been honored here
about a boy who
watched movies
in a north Belfast
working-class household,
including seeing
the Oscar ceremony
beamed to the north of Ireland,
and that same story is taking
me back to the real place.
But this time I'm
seeing it from the stage,
not from my front room
on television.
So that is an idea to really
get your head around.
Enjoy everything.
Enjoy this moment.
Enjoy watching movies,
which I did.
Part of what happened in Belfast
is you got a chance
to put your love for the
movies and your love
for the place
that you came from,
where you started
watching movies
on the screen,
you put your heart there
and you put your instinct there.
You wrote it
because you had to.
So I'd say to my younger self,
just try and do all the things
you need to do,
all the stories you have
to tell or try and tell
because they're the best ones.